ah it's New Years Eve that time of the
year when we focus on new beginnings and
make resolutions to better ourselves
it's a practice that can be traced back
almost 4000 years
to Babylon where people reportedly made
promises of loyalty to their king and
the gods and swore to pay back their
debts today in 2015 more than 40% of
Americans made New Year's resolutions
and these personal commitments have a
serious effect on industry in the United
States January is the biggest month of
the year for new health club memberships
but lots of people never even make it to
the gym more than once or twice it's
also the month when the most smokers
decide to quit and many are also looking
to cut the gut in fact Weight Watchers
says they ramped up their marketing and
advertising around New Year's Eve and
dating websites like mass comm say they
get the most new traffic at the
beginning of the year as people renew
their quest to find love and even though
only 8% of people usually follow through
in their resolutions it's a practice
that we just can't seem to give up so
what will you resolve to do in 2016